c'est ici dans le nouveau centre de tri
de la chine qui est envoyé une grande
partie de ce que les montréalais mettent
dans leurs bacs de récupération
mais après un an d'opération la machine
à trier le verre qui a coûté 3 millions
de dollars est toujours dans la cour en
pièces détachées
c'est un dossier projet montréal est
l'administration plante complètement
bousillé alors que l'administration
plantes fondé beaucoup d'espoirs dans
cette machine pour améliorer le
recyclage du verre
l'ancien gestionnaire du centre de tri
le groupe tiru qui a fait faillite ne
l'a jamais installé
résultat depuis un an environ 15 mille
tonnes de verre ont été envoyés dans des
sites d'enfouissement
montréal et même dans le bac de
récupération je trouve qu'après un an
c'est pas acceptable à la ville de
montréal on nous précise que pour
l'instant le verre est utilisé comme
recouvrement dans des sites
d'enfouissement
mais le nouveau gestionnaire du centre
de tri promet que les choses vont
changer
reste posée l'installer benneteau on
lance tranquillement pas vite avec tout
qu'est ce qu'on est vraiment c'est quand
ils eux aussi mais il n'ya pas que le
ver qui pose des défis
même si la ville a dépensé 50 millions
de dollars pour que le centre de tri
soit la fine pointe de la technologie
on retrouve encore beaucoup de
contaminants d'impuretés dans les
matières qui sont triés
parce que le rodage n'est pas encore
terminée dans les ballots de papier par
exemple on retrouve 17% de contaminants
c'est mieux que la moyenne québécoise
mais pour cette environnementalistes
c'est beaucoup trop parce que le poids
des pays d'asie ont fermé leur porte
justement parce que les taux de
contamination est trop élevé ils
accepteront les matières recyclables de
l'amérique les pays comme la chine ou
d'autres mecs des taux de contamination
qui frôle un ou deux pourcent là malgré
tout l'argent investi dans le projet le
président de ricoh va crois qu'il faut
en injecter encore pour acheter plus
d'équipements pour améliorer la qualité
du tri si incapable de pouce en
sectionnant un cadet il faut investir
beaucoup
il faut ralentir les l'un des traits
avec des ballots de papier de meilleure
qualité on espère trouver de nouveaux
débouchés au québec mais également
l'étranger ici jean philippe robien
radio canada montréal